Let's talk about Meghan Markle's etiquette.
She closed her own car door.
What is the big deal about that?
Usually, if you are a member of the royal family or a dignitary,...
...you have a member of the staff...
...to open and close the car door for you.
That's not there to propel airs and graces.
It's there from a security point of view.
What are some other things that Meghan can't do?
Now that Meghan is a member of the Royal Family,...
...there's no more selfies.
There are no more autographs.
She can't vote in any election or any referendum...
...and all public social media has to be deleted.
Now, that said, the royal family from the younger generations...
...are known to have private Facebook and Instagram accounts.
But these handles are not known by we members of the public.